(sirènes de police)
C'est le procès du siècle,
diront certains.
Un procès sous haute
surveillance et très médiatisé.
Il y a la guerre en Ukraine,
le droit à l'avortement remis
en question. Mais enen à faire:
ce qui fascine les Américains,
c'est ce procès en diffamation
que mène Johnny Depp contre
son ex-femme, Amber Heard.
- Johnny!
(acclamations)
Chaque jour depuis le 11 avril,
ses fans sont nombreux devant
leriribunal, iPhone à la main,
pour immortaliser ce moment :
Johnny Depp qui les salue
avec le sourire.
(sirènes de police)
- "It's Johnny Depp!"
(rire)
- "Let's take a break.
Let's go see Johnny Depp!"
- Mais à l'intérieur de la cour,
il n'y a rien de joyeux.
Amber Heard l'accuse
de violence physique,
psychologique, verbale,
surtout déclenchée lors d'une
forte consommation d'alcool
et de drogue.
Depuis un mois, leur vie privée
est devenue publique. Tout est
relaté dans les moindres détaila
télévision, avec vidéos et audio
à l'appui. Le public se délecte.
"Tout leur linge sale est exposé
devant le monde entier",
dit cette avocate qui couvre
le procès depuis le début.
"Il s'agit de diffamation,
dit-elle. Et tout repose surqui.
"Je ne l'aime pas, c'est
une menteuse," dit-elle.
"Elle pleure, mais elle n'a pas
de larmes" dit la pancarte.
"Nous n'étions pas là,
dit-il. On n'est pas en mesure
de juger, comme société.
Il y a un système pour cela."
Mais chaque avocat a son point
de vue.
"Les personnes qui prétendent
être victimes de violences
conjugales sont extrêmement
dangereuses," dit-elle" pour
les vraies victimes."
"Son histoire ne tient pas"
dit-elle. "Amber Heard n'a pas
toujours porté plaelelelelelle
refuse des soins médicaux, alors
qu'elle aurait subi des graves
blessures".
Et c'est ce que Johnny Depp
essaie de prouver, qu'Amber
Heard n'a pas dit la vérité.
Selon l'acteur, elle n'a fait
que ternir sa réputation et lui
ererererererdre plusieurs contrs
importants, dont celui du film
"Pirates des Caraïbes".
"Quelle que soit l'issue
du procès, dit-il je vais vivre
avec ça pour le reste
de mes jours." Il nie avoir levé
la main sur elle et réclame
50 millions de dollars
en dommages et intérêts.
"Le pendule du mouvement #MeToo
ne balançait que d'un côté,
dit cette avocate. Beaucoup
d'hommes ont été
de violence conjugale,
et certains étaient juste
pris dans ce mouvement et
n'ont pas eu la possibilité
de se défendreen court. Johnny
Depp a décidé de riposter,
en se présentant aussi comme
une victime" dit-elle.
Avec cette poursuite,
Johnny Depp aura semé le douten,
il a déjà remporté la bataille
populaire.
Le contre-interrogatoire
d'Amber Heard débute le 16 mai
prochain.
Iciororororororororghis,
Radio-Canada, Fairfax,
Virgini